Hi,
welcome back to human emotion.
Today I'm very excited to be
continuing our discussion on happiness.
And as we discussed in our
last lecture as humans,
it seems that we have this almost,
you know,
insatiable desire or yearning to both be
happy and understand what happiness is.
So today we're going to start again with
the ancient observation of Aristotle
who emphasize just how important
happiness is to humans.
He said happiness is the
meaning and the purpose of life,
the whole aim and end of human existence.
So today in our second module on happiness
and wellbeing will be pushing our
understanding of happiness one step
further by looking at how it relates to
morality.
And in some ways try to look at this
question of how can morality influence
happiness? Is there any way in
which the two are intertwined?
We'll be doing this today by starting
with a very special guest lecture by Josh
Nobe here at Yale University,
followed by our takeaway
questions and expert interview.
So we'll first start with our
guests lecture by Dr Josh Nobe.
Um, so our very special guest lecture
today is by Dr Josh Nobe on morality.
And happiness.
Josh is a professor of cognitive science
and philosophy at Yale University and
is one of the founders of the
experimental philosophy movement.
His work has also been
covered by the New York Times,
the BBC slate and scientific American.
So welcome Josh.
Thank you for your special
guest lecture today.
Thanks so much.
So today we're going to be taking a step
in a slightly different direction and
we're going to try to take a
more interdisciplinary approach.
So just as in all of the
previous segments of this course,
we're going to be using the kind
of standard methods of psychology.
We're going to be looking at experiments,
statistical analyses and so forth.
But in this segment we're also going
to be taking a different approach.
We're going to be looking at certain
questions that came out of philosophy and
certain ideas that philosophers have
developed about those questions.
So in essence,
then what we're going to be doing is when
we be ticking philosophical questions
and philosophers ideas
about those questions.
But then we're going to be putting those
ideas to the test using the kind of
standard methods that
we see in psychology.
So this approach of mixing philosophy and
psychology in this way is often called
experimental philosophy.
And that's the kind of approach
we're going to be pursuing here.
So in keeping with this kind
of interdisciplinary approach,
we're going to be talking about work
from an interdisciplinary team of
researchers.
So in particular we're going to be
talking about work from Jonathan Phillips
from philosophy, your
instructor, John Gruber,
from psychology and Julian to Fritas
from an interdisciplinary program in
cognitive science.
And the question that these researchers
were interested in was the kind of
philosophical question about how to
understand what we even mean when we talk
about happiness.
So for example,
suppose that we pick out a particular
person and we posed the question,
is this person truly happy?
The philosophical question now is,
what does that question even mean?
What is it that we're really trying to
ask when we ask that kind of question?
And a typical answer that a lot of people
have thought might be right is that in
asking that question,
we're basically just asking a
question about this person's states.
So a person would be considered happy
to the extent that that person has high
positive effect.
So a lot of positive emotions to extend
through the person has low negative
effort. So very few negative
emotions. And finally,
to the extent that the person has a lot
of life satisfaction there is to say has
to believe that her life is fundamentally
going in the right direction.
So according to this view,
as long as you have these certain
kinds of psychological states,
be right to say that you are happy.
But some philosophers have thought
maybe that view is not quite right.
Maybe there's actually more to the story.
Maybe there's something further
going on. So those, for us,
we thought maybe we can actually develop
a counter example to this kind of
general theory about what
happiness is all about.
So this thought is basically this.
Suppose we mentioned someone
who has all of the states,
someone has a lot of positive emotion,
very little negative emotion,
someone who was extremely satisfied
with the way her life is going.
But now suppose we imagine because
that person has a really evil,
nasty sort of person.
Supposedly.
Imagine that her life is fundamentally
kind of Vapid and meaningless and she has
no real friends,
that she's cruel and various ways to
other people to suggestion that these
philosophers mid then was that even
if she has all of these kinds of
psychological states,
we might say that she's not truly happy.
So on this kind of view,
maybe it's not right to say that
happiness is just a matter of having these
kinds of states.
So now we face the question,
we started out with this
idea from philosophy and
idea that maybe happiness is
more than just a matter of having these
certain kinds of psychological states
and we do not want to use these methods
from psychology to test that idea out to
see if it's actually correct.
And the way we're going to do this is
by presenting participants with certain
kinds of stories,
but people have various kinds of lives
and then asking those participants
whether the people in the
stories actually are happy.
So each participant is going
to be randomly assigned to
get either a story about
someone who's leading a good life
or someone who's leading a bad life.
In the actual experiment,
there were four different pairs that
participants can be randomly assigned to
receive,
but just to kind of give an example to
give you a sense of what this experiment
was like.
We're just going to pick one of these
pairs and you can see what happened in the
good life condition and what
happened in the bad life condition.
So participants in the
good life condition,
it received a story about someone
who has a really angelic, wholesome,
wonderful form of life,
so they were told,
Maria is the mother of three children
who all really love her. In fact,
they couldn't imagine having a better mom.
Maria usually stays pretty busy
taking care of her children.
She often finds herself rushing from
one birthday party to the next and it's
always going to pick up some groceries
or buy school supplies. Well,
Maria has been preoccupied
with her children.
She does get to see her old friends
occasionally, almost every night.
She ends up working on some project for
the next day or planning something for
our children's future.
And then these participants were
given some information about Maria
psychological states in particular that
they were told that she has a whole lot
of positive effect,
very little negative effect.
And then she has a great
deal of life satisfaction.
And then just to make sure
that participants really
accepted this information,
they were given some simple
reading comprehension questions,
just true or false questions
in which they're asked.
Is it really the case that she
has a lot of positive effect,
very little negative effects
and very high life satisfaction.
And just as you might guess,
participants overwhelmingly answered
true to all of these questions and then
came the real question.
Given all this information,
is it right to say that Maria is,
how can you,
so this first kiss might seem
like a relatively simple one,
probably you don't feel very conflicted
as far as you find yourself trying to
answer this question,
but participants in the other condition
got a story about another and Maria,
what a very different form of life.
So in this condition,
participants were told Maria wants to
live the life of a celebrity in La.
In fact, she has even started
trying to date a few famous people.
Maria usually stays pretty
busy trying to become popular.
She often finds herself rushing from
one party to the next and there's always
going to pick up some alcohol or address.
Maria is so preoccupied with becoming
popular that she's no longer concerned
with being honest or nicer old friends
unless they know someone famous almost
every night she ends up either drunk or
doing some type of drug just like the
famous people. She wants to be like, see,
this life was described in such a way as
to make it as Vapid as meaningless and
as callous as possible.
And then after this information was given,
participants were told about
Maria psychological states
and what they were told
was just exactly the same information
as in the other condition.
So participants were told that she
has a whole lot of positive emotions,
very little negative emotions, and then
she's highly satisfied with her life.
Just can't even imagine anything
that you'd rather be doing.
So participants in this next condition
then received again the exact same
reading comprehension questions
is the first participants.
So once again participants were asked,
is it really the case that she
has a lot of positive effects,
very little negative effect and
high judgment of life satisfaction.
And once again prisons overwhelmingly
answered yes to all of these questions and
now comes the key question. Participants
in this ladder at Quinn condition,
we're asked is it right to
say that Maria is happy?
So participants have just indicated
that Rhea has high positive affect,
low negative effect,
high judgments of life satisfaction.
So if the fact that all there is to being
happy, they should obviously say yes,
of course she's happy,
that's just what it means to be happy.
But if the philosophers are right that
something is more is going on here,
then participants answer might
actually be slightly different.
And if you look at the results,
will you find is that that's exactly what
occurred in each of the cases where a
person described as having a good life.
Participants overwhelmingly agreed
that that person actually was happy.
But if you turned out to the case in
which the person was described as having a
bad life,
you find this strange kind of reluctance.
Even though the person's described as
having all of their psychological states,
we'd associate with happiness,
people are giving that person a happiness
ratings right around the mid point you
who that person is unhappy nor
that the person is truly happy.
So what is going on here?
Why is this occurring?
Why is it that when
someone has a bad life,
people say that she's not truly happy.
So we were really puzzled by this result
and it's still very difficult to figure
out why it's happening. We wanted to
try out one particular possibility.
So in particular I teamed up with George
Newman from the school of management
and Paul Bloom from
developmental psychology and
we tried to test out the idea
that maybe the effect here has something
to do with the notion that people have
a kind of true self,
I kind of essential self or self
or they have really deep down.
So the hypothesis here is maybe people
think of the sophos having certain kinds
of layers on the surface of the self.
You might think it's something
like the superficial stuff,
just the way that yous people seem to be
feeling if you just looked in the most
superficial way,
but then maybe people think there's also
something deeper that fundamentally at
the kind of core of a person's
being like something further,
something that we might
call the true self.
And in particular we thought that maybe
people's moral judgments seem to have an
impact on our intuitions about
what's going on at this deeper level.
So suppose that at a superficial level,
a person seems to be really happy
with things that are totally bad.
So even though they're doing something
that's really wrong or cruel to others,
they seem to be completely
satisfied with it.
We thought maybe people think that in
such a self there's some deeper core
fundamental essence that's calling
on them to do something good.
But importantly we thought that this
would affect would be asymmetric if on the
surface someone was doing something good,
we thought people wouldn't think
deep down at the core of their being.
There was something calling
on them to be more a bad.
So we tested out this hypothesis
with a simple experiment.
They used a three by two design.
So participants in one condition got
a whole mix of different stories.
Some of our people who are on the surface,
we're doing something bad.
Some of our people who on the surface
we're doing something good and some of our
people who are doing on the
surface doing something neutral.
Then participants in the other condition
just got their reverse of each of those
stories. So the bad stories, by reversing
them, it turned into good stories.
The good stories when they reversed
turn it about stories and the neutral
stories when reversed remained neutral.
And then in each of these
cases participants were
just asked whether there was
some fundamental layer
of the person's self.
There was calling that person to do
something different than what these seemed
to be enjoying doing under surface.
So just to give you a sense
of how this experiment worked.
Here is an example of one of the bad
vignettes. Participants were taught,
Bill has always mistreated his employees.
He often yells at them and
publicly embarrassing them
for minor infractions and
has never expressed any interest in
trying to impede in to treat his employees
better. And then participants were asked
how much do you agree with the following
statement even though he might not
acknowledge it to other people or even at
himself and his very essence,
there's something deep within bill calling
him to stop mistreating has employers.
So you can just try thinking this question
over for yourself and see whether you
strongly disagree with this statement.
Strongly agree or whether you're
sort of somewhere in the middle.
Then participants in the good condition
would receive something like a reversed
version of the bad case. Bill has
always treated his employees very well.
He never yells at them or does anything
to publicly embarrassment and has never
expressed any interest in
treating his employees poorly.
And then they just got the same question.
Do the agree the,
even though he might not acknowledge it
to other people or even in soft and his
very essence,
there is something deep within bill
calling him to start mistreating his
employers.
And finally in the neutral case,
participants would get stories that
we're completely neutral in their moral
Vance. Jim has been a red
wine drinker for many years.
He only drinks red wine and has never
expressed any interest in drinking white
wine.
So what do you think?
Is it the case that even though he might
not acknowledge it to other people or
even himself and his very essence,
there's something deep within him that's
calling him to start drinking red,
white wine? Or in the
reverse case, if there,
if on the surface he's
drawn to drinking red wine,
is there something deep within him calling
him in the opposite direction toward
white wine? So we can now
look at the results and we're
looking at these results,
not for each separate vignette,
but pulling together all of the vignettes
that were had this character of being
good.
All the ones that are the character of
being neutral and all the ones that on
the surface had the
character of being bad.
And what we see here is a
linear progression where
if someone's on the surface
being good,
people are very disinclined to say
that there's something deep within that
person calling them to be bad.
If someone's on the surface being neutral,
it's at least possible that there's
something deep within him calling him in a
different direction.
But most of all,
when someone on the surface
is doing from the bad,
people are very inclined to think there
might be something deep within that
person calling that person to
do something that's more good.
So it's this idea that we want
to capitalize in. What follows,
we thought maybe this could be the
explanation of the effects that we saw
earlier in people's
judgments of happiness.
So recall the basic idea
behind those effects.
We looked at people had a good knife and
people had a bad life and we found this
difference that when people
are having a good life,
people are more inclined to say that
person was happy then where people were
having a bad life,
even holding fixed.
All the information we provided about
that person's psychological states.
So why is that happening?
One explanation would be that it follows
from something about the way people are
construing the true stuff.
So in the good life case,
the information being provided says
that that on the surface the person is
really happy with her life and
because she's having a good life,
people seem to be assuming the deep down
the view that she's feeling having you
sort of concordance with the
view that she has on the surface,
that she really does feel deep down.
That same thing that she appears
to be filling on the surface,
that this wholesome, angelic life
she's living really is a good one.
But now suppose we turned to
the bad life case. In that case,
participants are again told that on the
surface she has all of these positive
states, positive emotion,
very little negative emotion,
lots of life satisfaction.
But if this kind of theory
about the true self is right,
maybe participants think that deep down
at her core she is actually feeling
something very different.
The deep down there's something within
her calling her toward a different way of
life,
a way of life.
There would be different fundamentally
from the one that she's been living so
far.
So to test out this theory,
we presented people with
exactly those same vineyards.
There were used in the original
study to study happiness.
So some people were told about
someone who has a really angelic list.
Some people were told about someone who
has this much more vapid and meaningless
life,
but then we ask them additional question.
So first that each participant was asked
that same question that they received
in the original case. Is it right to
say that this agent is happy or not?
But there was also a further variable.
Each participant was also
asked whether the agreed there.
Deep down this agent actually feels very
differently about her life from the way
she feels on the surface.
So now within a single experiment we can
measure both people's intuitions about
happiness and their intuitions about
the true self and we could look at the
relationship among these
different variables.
So we have for each participant whether
that participant was in the bad life
condition or not,
whether the participants said that the
agent was experiencing true happiness or
not,
and whether the participants thought
that deep down there was something within
that person's true stuff,
calling her to lead a different life,
we can now look at the relationships
among all these different variables.
What we find first is just
replicating the earlier study.
When participants hear story
about 200 is a very bad life,
they're less inclined to think
that that person is truly happy,
but we're also getting this other effect.
When someone has a bad life,
there are more inclined to say that
the person that feels very deeply
differently deep down in their true south.
And finally,
if you look at this variable and this one,
you find that the more participants think
that deep down in someone's shoes off,
there's something calling them
towards a different way of life,
the more they think that the
person is not truly happy.
So we can now use a statistical technique
called mediation analysis to examine
the impact of all these variables.
And what we find is that the impact
of the bad life on people's happiness
judgments is mediated by true
soft judgments. In other words,
what seems to be happening is that
when you hear the tone is a bad life,
you conclude that there's
something deep within that person.
The person's choose off that's calling
them to live in a different way.
And it's that that makes you think
that that person's not truly happy.
So to recap now that path of
the whole discussion so far,
we saw that philosophers have thought
that there's an impact of morality and
judgments of happiness.
And in particularly as the thought that
if someone's living a life that's really
immoral,
it'd be wrong.
And somehow it seems strange to see
that that person is truly happy.
We wanted to do is to
test that hypothesis.
Do people actually feel that way and to
figure out why people feel that way if
they do? So, first of all, we found that
people do seem to have that intuition.
They think that if your life is
morally bad, you can't truly be happy.
And now we seem to be getting some
insight into at least one possible
explanation of why it might be a crime.
Maybe what's happening is that people's
ordinary understanding of happiness
isn't just an understanding
of feeling positive emotion,
not feeling negative emotion,
having a lot of life satisfaction,
but rather involves something
sort of deeper, more fundamental.
Maybe it involves a certain
kind of contentment,
not just on the surface of the self, but
deep down at the level of the truce off.
Thanks so much.
So thank you so much for that.
Fantastic guests lecture, Josh.
Now what we're going to do is move
to our takeaway questions for today.
So our takeaway questions from our very
special guest lecture by Dr Josh Nobe
are as follows.
First,
what are the three components of happiness
that were discussed today? Second,
what were the key distinctions made
between the good life and the bad life and
yet that were depicted today and how
did these distinct moral yet influenced
participants' descriptions and
understanding of happiness? Finally,
can you describe the true self theory
discussed today and what where it relates
to our understandings of happiness?
And now I'd like to conclude
with our expert interview.
This is part of our experts in emotion
interview series today for our experts
and emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with Dr. Daniel Gilbert,
a professor of psychology at Harvard
University on happiness. Dr. Gilbert, um,
is a professor of psychology and has
won numerous awards for his research and
teaching,
including the American Psychological
Association's Distinguished Scientific
Award for an early career contribution
to psychology. And in 2008,
he was elected to the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences.
Here's 2007 book stumbling on happiness.
Spent six months on the New York Times
bestseller list has been translated into
30 languages and was awarded the Royal
Society's General Book Prize for the Best
Science Book of the year.
In 2010 he hosted and cowrote the
award winning Novus television series,
this emotional life, which has been
seen by more than 10 million viewers.
He's also a contributor at a time,
the New York Times,
and NPR is all things considered and
has been a guest on numerous television
shows, including the today show, Charlie
rose 2020 and the Colbert report.
So finally,
his first head talk on happiness is now
one of the 15 most popular of all time.
So I now turn to our very special experts
in emotion interview together with Dr.
Daniel Gilbert on happiness.